domani nei palazzi romani natale chissà
cosa mi aveva portato babbo natale spero
tanto che mi abbia portato la navicella
turchi e lo voglio tanto bene riesco
aspettare fino a domani si vede un onore
forse arrivato babbo natale che se fate
vedere che non posso mette se mi vede
poi riportarle coni una sbirciatina solo
una un altro episodio e poi dormo sono
domani ti senti parenti farmi devo
svegliare e poi c'è il pranzo poi
l'apertura ai regali più così è stato
i ladri
e natale natale in india libano antenne
è arrivato babbo natale stupendi dalle
stelle gode di cielo è che ieri in una
grotta al petto e bello torino sbrigati
stiamo aspettando solo star arrivo
ancora due minuti
dovete capire che milo truccare per le
foto e dai nuovi tv ci sono i regali
arrivo
non posso aprire legali non ancora amore
adesso no e quando posso aprire libero
aspetta ancora un pochino e adesso va
bene dai aprili cosa pi grazie non
dovevi davvero
ma poiché bel pacchetto le foto tu
guarda che bello il nostro di velluto
quasi mi dispiace aprirlo vabbè vado
piano piano è guarda c'è ma guarda che
caria io questa la conservo amore aprire
gallo dello zio questo o quell'altro
eccolo lì sì
[Musica]
no non ci credo come è fatta solo che mi
piaceva ti giuro che da un mese che dico
che voglio questo voglio in cina sei
l'unico che azzeccato regalo è
bellissimo è una pellicola che preferite
muore stai ferma di che faccio una foto
sorridi prendi regali famiglie delegare
brava sorority che bella che sei di
profilo da davanti così però spetta
prendo prendo un regalo sa non sembrano
tanti
le feste tipo naturale come se non
stesse accorgendo quindi tipo poi così
[Musica]
questo signore di farci vedere cosa ha
portato babbo natale da babbo natale
abbiamo portato la cagnetta alla
navicella che lo volevo poi mi ha
attaccato la rabbia degli bardi e poi
stacca che la scimmietta e saluta
ringrazia la zia grazie via e ringrazio
anche la nonna
grazie nonna ringrazio tutta la famiglia
grazie
il brano che voglia giocare ma sta
ciao ragazzi ho appena aperto in i
regali di natale sono felicissimo perché
sono tutti i top
adoro ma non posso ancora spoilerarvi
nulla quindi per il momento vi posso
solo dire che se questo video arriverà a
100mila like vi farò vedere i miei
regali e mi raccomando iscrivetevi al
canale fa vedere contenuto
[Musica]